AMERICANS FIRST AND FOREMOST.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
RAJ SHAW.
CARTER PAGE ADVISED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND LATER MONITORED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TREATED
HIM LIKE A SPY.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CARTER THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: JUST TO GET THIS OUT
OF THE WAY, DID YOU HELP ANY OF
THESE DIETED RUSSIANS SET UP
FAKE FACEBOOK PAGES OR PLAN ANY
OF THEIR SPARSELY ATTENDED
RALLIES FOR THEM?
>> THE ONLY FACEBOOK SHE NAN I
FANS THAT WERE HAPPENING WITH
STATE SPONSORED MEDIA WAS RADIO
FREE EUROPE, THEY PUBLISHED THIS
FAKE NEWS FROM THE DODGY DOSSIER
IN SEPTEMBER 2016.
AND THAT WAS REBROADCASTED BY A
SPONSORED MEDIA OUTLET, RADIO
FREE EUROPE, SPONSORED BY
BROADCASTING BOARD OF GOVERNORS
OUT OF WASHINGTON.
THAT'S THE CLOSEST I HAD WITH
ANY SORT OF GOVERNMENT SPONSORED
NEWS OUTLETS.
NO.
>> Monica: SO, YOU'RE AN
ANNAPOLIS GRADUATE, NAVAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER FOR FIVE
YEARS, PRESUMABLY THAT MARKS YOU
AS A PATRIOTIC AMERICAN.
DID YOU IMAGINE THAT YOUR
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE SPYING ON
YOU AT ANY POINTS?
>> WELL, I MEAN I HAD SOME
WARNINGS ABOUT THAT BACK IN
STARTING IN THE SUMMER OF 2016
AND INTO SEPTEMBER.
IT ACTUALLY, WHEN I SENT MY
LETTER TO DIRECTOR COMEY ON
SEPTEMBER 25, 2016 I WAS, YOU
KNOW, IMMEDIATELY CALLED THIS
OUT AS A WITCH HUNT.
SO I HAD SOME ADVANCE WARNING
ABOUT THAT.
AND I ALSO WARNED HIM ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, AND I SAID INSTEAD OF
ALLOWING THE STAFF OF THE FBI TO
FOCUS BLENDED RESOURCES ON REAL
THREATS, DESPERATE AND UNFOUNDED
CALLS FOR MY INVESTIGATION AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN ARE A TRUE
DISGRACE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, AS WE SAW
THIS WEEK, DOWN IN FLORIDA THAT
PREDICTION TURNED OUT TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON SOME OF
THESE REAL THREATS OUT THERE
THEY WERE WASTING A TREMENDOUS
RESOURCES ON THIS COMPLETE WITCH
HUNT.
>> Tucker: AND VIOLATING YOUR
CIVIL LIBER TUS.
ONE OF THE REASONS THEY WERE
ABLE TO GET A FISA WARRANT TO
BREAK INTO YOUR LIFE AND SPY ON
YOU IS BECAUSE OF THIS DOSSIER,
WHICH WE RERODE LAST WEEK I HAD
FORGOTTEN THE ALLEGATION THAT
YOU RECEIVED A PERCENTAGE OF A
RUSSIAN COMPANY, SHARES IN THAT
COMPANY, WHICH WOULD BE WORTH
ABOUT $11 BILLION.
I GUESS THE OBVIOUS QUESTION IS,
DID YOU EVER GET $11 BILLION
FROM THE RUSSIANS FOR SPYING ON
THE UNITED STATES FOR BETRAYING
YOUR COUNTRY?
>> I'M STILL WAITING FOR THAT,
TUCKER.
IT IS FUNNY, THE COMPANY THAT
DID END UP ACQUIRING THAT --
THOSE SHARES IS GLENCORP FOUNDED
BY MARK RICH, PARDONED IN THE
LAST DAYS OF THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: THE LAST DAY, I
THINK, YES.
SO, I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO
GET -- I DON'T EVEN KNOW YOU,
NEVER TALKED TO YOU BEFORE
TONIGHT.
AS I WATCH YOU, I WONDER, AS AN
ANNAPOLIS GRADUATE AND NAVAL
OFFICER OF COURSE YOUR LIFE
DESTROYED BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, WHAT DO YOU DO FOR
MONEY AND HOW MUCH HAS THIS COST
YOU AND WHAT HAS IT DONE TO YOUR
LIFE?
>> TUCKER, THE LAST MAJOR
INTELLIGENCE NAILURE BY THE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY LED TO
DEATHS OF THOUSANDS OF U.S.
MILITARY CITIZENS -- MILITARY
OFFICERS AND SOLDIERS AND
AIRMEN.
TO ME THIS IS A MINOR COST.
I JUST, I'M JUST THANKFUL THAT
THIS FALSE INTELLIGENCE THAT WAS
PUT INTO THE BLOODSTREAM OF THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT WAS NOT FOLLOWED
UP ON, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ABLE TO CALL THIS OUT FOR THE
COMPLETE LIES THAT IT -- AND
MISINFORMATION IT WAS.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY YOU NEVER
GOT THE $11 BILLION IN BLOOD